what is the most ethical career path
that you can choose can it be possible
that a career in consulting or banking
is more ethical than a career as a
medical doctor so these are the
questions that i'd like to investigate
with you today to clearly say this in
the beginning of course i am aware that
the proposition of this video might be a
little bit controversial the main
purpose for me why i created this video
is also more to just introduce you to
this line of thinking and hopefully
inspire some of you to think more about
how you can turn your career into a
force for good this is more important to
me than arguing what exactly the most
ethical career paths are i graduated
with a bachelor of philosophy in my
undergrad i focused a lot on ethics meta
ethics and political philosophy and here
i thought that this might be a great
topic it draws from an area of
philosophy that is called the ethics of
career choice that investigates exactly
these questions so let's start this
video with a little thought experiment
this one got popularized by peter singer
a quite well-known contemporary
philosopher he started his career at
oxford and now is a professor at
princeton and he describes the following
scenario so let's imagine you're on your
way to work and on this way there is a
pond and you see in the pond that there
is a kid and the kid is screaming for
help the kid seems to be about to drown
and you are a good swimmer you would be
able to just jump in and likely pull the
kid out of the pond and thereby likely
save that kid's life but would you do it
because if you do it you would come late
to work you're wearing a fancy
tailor-made suit the pawn looks a bit
dirty so like you will need to throw
away the suit this will have cost you
several thousand bucks and after all
it's not your kid it's not your fault
that the kid is in the pond you have
nothing to do with it so think about
this for yourself would you jump in save
the kid even though this leads to
damages of your clothes of a couple of
thousand dollars and indeed lots of
research has been conducted exactly on
this thought experiment and i think it's
no surprise that the big majority of all
the people confronted with this
situation said yes of course i would
save the kid of course i wouldn't care
if i damaged my clothes many people
would find it outlandish that anyone
would just consider not doing that
consider not saving the kid in such a
situation though if we hold this to be
true how is this consistent with the
fact that every day people die from
hunger thirst curable illnesses and
other consequences of extreme poverty
where it's just the fact that the
majority of people don't do anything
about and here it would be possible just
with small sums a couple of hundred
dollar a couple of thousand dollar you
could save these people you could save
these people's life so this is a
contradiction right that you are facing
on the one hand in this first scenario
you would absolutely go for it do it on
the other scenario most of us apparently
do not seem to be willing to save these
people's lives even though we would be
able to have an impact so now you might
ask yourself well that's interesting and
all but what the heck does this have to
do with ethics of career choice with
whether a consulting career is ethical
or not so before we dive into this let's
pause this for a moment and rather agree
on some terms and definitions because of
course one of the key questions to
answer is what do we even mean by that
what is an ethical career choice after
all and so for this video i'm adopting a
consequentialist view which says
something like an ethical career choice
leads to a career path that enables you
to influence the world in a positive way
i.e to have positive consequences in the
world and surely why of course different
types of consequences exist i'd say just
to simplify it a little bit a good proxy
would be to save lives or at least
significantly improve the living
conditions of other people and so in my
view while surely you might come up with
other aspects that would inform this i'd
say it's really difficult to argue that
if a career leads to positive
consequences like this it would not be
considered an ethical career path now
the next question might be how we assess
whether a career indeed has these
positive consequences or not and i want
to propose the standard of counter
factual reasoning what this means is
that to assess the consequences of your
actions and your career path you should
compare the state of the world if you
would pursue the career with the state
of the world if you would not pursue the
career and the delta of these two
situations these two states this is the
impact of your actions the impact of the
career that you choose now following
these standards what are the best career
paths that you should pursue to live an
ethical life following this definition
and here one fact that i find to be
quite powerful is that the average
person works about 80 000 hours in his
or her life 80 000 hours that's a very
significant part of your life indeed so
surely we should make sure that these 80
000 hours matter and there's one quite
popular website in this field called
80000.ok
that compares different career paths
exactly by these moral ethical standards
so let's investigate different
archetypes of career paths for their
ethical merits so let's start with the
direct benefactors these are careers
that positively impact other people in a
positive way a good example would be a
medical doctor next are the influencers
these are the people that motivate and
inspire other people to do good people
who want to spread the ideas of
effective altruism which is the name of
the movement and many of the ideas i'm
sharing it today are drawn from and of
course these people can have a great
impact as they multiply the ideas and
the many many other people do good
hopefully due to their instigation next
are researchers so people doing research
in relevant fields that improve the
living conditions of many people around
the world an example would surely be
research on renewable energies last but
not least the high earners and these are
surely people working in consulting
working in banking in professional
services in general so people who
dedicated their life to work in careers
that enabled them to earn more the most
other people around them and then of
course the idea is that these people
then can use these funds to donate to
organizations who do improve the world
in a better way well now while in
principle all these careers can do good
let's add the additional standard of
counter factual reasoning this one says
that to assess your impact you need to
envision the world if you would not
pursue this career with the world in
which you do pursue this career let's
look into the example of a medical
doctor at least in western countries
there are many more people who'd like to
become nmd compared to the people
actually can study the subject of
medicine and have the chance to do so so
if you are not pursuing the career of
nmd there will be someone else filling
your spot and your counter factual
contribution your counter factual impact
will only be the extent to which you are
better than the next best candidate on
the list who would have filled your spot
and of course it's quite difficult to
argue that this impact is very
significant after all so let's contrast
that with a career in banking or in
finance because here surely the vast
majority of people that just affect do
not donate a significant amount of their
salary every month every year so if you
are pursuing this career and potentially
are able to replace the next best
candidate who very likely will not have
done that and you are a person that
would be willing to donate only 10 20
of your net income to some charitable
causes this data suddenly can be quite
significant and you will have a real
impact also by this counterfactual
standard so this is the line of
reasoning that some people employ to
claim that their career in investment
banking can be more ethical and for
instance a career as an md of course the
caveat to that is that surely horses nmd
at least in many different fields you
will earn a significant amount of money
as well and then of course you have the
opportunity by the fact that you become
a high earner as well to upgrade your
impact that you can have on the world
also by this counterfactual standard so
let's see how the team from
80000.org sees this because they really
investigate all types of different
career paths and their summary their
main conclusion is that they identified
these five career paths that from their
perspective are the most ethical most
impactful ones so what you can see here
as well is that becoming an md did not
really make the list but instead they're
talking about government and policy in
an area relevant to a top problem this
would be one of their top five choices
or organization building at effective
non-profits so leading building up these
charities that really do good in the
world third research and relevant areas
we just talked about this fourth
applying an unusual skill to a needed
niche so this is to the point of you
having a very specific very special
talent that you can apply to really
create something good and then number
five earning to give so this is of
course exactly what we just talked about
pursuing a high earner career indeed can
be one of the most impactful things that
you can do so then indeed they write
about so what's the best way to earn to
give so you look for some options where
you have a great fit make sure it is a
high earning path with a good outlook it
offers flexible career capitals that
you're not locked in but can potentially
also transition in other fields and of
course it doesn't cause harm so let's
talk about this in a moment as well
because of course i know that this is a
common prejudice against consulting or
banking that they do cause lots of
harmony so which jobs are highest paying
so here they talk about jobs and finance
management medicine from the perspective
of being high earner law real estate and
so on then they go on by talking about
what the best options overall are to
earn to give and as you can see here
management consulting did make the list
but let's now do briefly talk about the
point of not causing harm and this is
also a question that they address on
their side and just not to quote them
they say but don't many high earning
jobs cause harm where you of course
don't recommend taking a job that does a
lot of harm in order to donate the money
in practice most people who earn to give
work in the fields of technology asset
management medicine or consulting and we
think that these positions do a small
amount of good or unusual for instance
many financial traders make profits at
the expense of other traders so they are
moving money around mostly from rich
people to other rich people and then of
course there are some people who cause
harm in this industry but that's true of
any industry and frankly this is also my
experience so i am of course also aware
of some of the news reports of some
consulting firms who allegedly did
things which really of course are
outrageous and surely if you're part of
any of these projects any of these
schemes you are definitely doing harm
while these things apparently do happen
and of course everyone should work hard
on avoiding situations where these
things might arise i frankly think it's
a bit unfair to claim that if you work
in professional services or in
consulting you will regularly be exposed
or even an active part on any of these
type of situations so assuming you
follow the argument until here you know
did make the choice to pursue a high
earning career path with the intention
to give back to donate some of the money
where the question is what shall i do
with the money until you might be
surprised what impact you already can
have with rather modest sums the
different internet sides comparing
organizations and courses that you can
donate to one of the as far as i know
quite popular websites in this area is
giveway.org there they list a couple of
courses which from their perspective
have a very high roi of course i cannot
personally endorse any of these
organizations here as always please do
your own research before you decide to
give money to any of these organizations
you could donate to malaria medicine so
apparently for seven dollar you would be
able to protect the child from malaria
which would lead to one saved life on
average every thousand five hundred
dollar that you donate another example
vitamin supplements so for one dollar
you can deliver vitamin a supplement
which on average leads to a saved life
for every three thousand dollars that
you donate or your last on the list the
dewarming treatments so for about one
dollar you are able to deworm a child
cure the child from these parasites
while these parasites might not be life
threatening they significantly decrease
the quality of life of these people and
often also significantly impact the
earnings potential of these people in
the future in a negative way so these
conditions go uncured this often means a
life in extreme poverty for the affected
people and these people could be held
for just one dollar for dewarming
treatment but i would of course be
interested in your perspective as well
what is the most ethical career path in
your opinion do you agree with the
arguments laid out in this video happy
to have a conversation with you about
exactly this if you took any value out
of this video at all as always please
destroy the like button for the youtube
algorithm and subscribe to stay up to
date on future content on this channel
big big thanks to all the members of the
channel thanks for your contribution my
name is heiner you release weekly videos
on how to become successful in the first
years of your career so stay tuned see
you again next week and bye